meanwhile Russia says its troops
captured several Ukrainian armored
vehicles and tanks while repelling a
counter-offensive in zapparisha on
Saturday footage released by the Russian
defense Ministry shows its forces
inspecting a german-made leopard tank
and two U.S Bradley infantry Vehicles
these were part of western military aid
to Kiev ahead of its counter-offensive
against Russian troops let's bring in
journalists Julia Chapo valva in Moscow
Julia what more are the Russians saying
about this battle in separation
oh Russia's top officials have
acknowledged the Ukrainian
counter-offensive is underway they do
not comment on Ukraine's gains and
successes but do admit heavy losses for
the Ukrainian side we see the military
activity uh stretching all along a huge
part of the front line from zapparagia
further down to the South the Russian
military bloggers have called the
Ukrainian attempts a failure but at the
Ukrainian end we hear that they haven't
actually started their proper offensive
they're currently using around 15 to 20
percent of their reserves testing
Russia's defenses trying to reveal their
weak spots uh domestically we keep
receiving reports about regular shelling
of Russia's border regions there was a
report by the governor of the Kursk
region of Russia the two border
villagers in the Kursk region were
Sheldon the early morning of June the
13th luckily no casualties were reported
but quite significant damage was caught
closed captioning not available